字幕志愿者 李宗盛
欢迎收看李财大人秀的歌有仇必报
第二季的第五集
第二季开播以来我们算是相当的随性
因为有时候教的东西有点难
有时候比较简单和基础
今天干脆怎么样呢
干脆请小哥本尊现身说法算了
到底我们教了这么多
小哥自己用哪一套
就像我们常常说
你代言很多產品的時候
你自己真的拿來抹的是什麼
小哥現在來告訴大家
他自己在用籌碼選股的時候
他的邏輯
他的順序
他的步驟是什麼
學起來你可能就是第二個
全證小哥有可能嗎
有可能
怎麼可能
小哥只有一個
哦
沒錯
小哥太久沒有來
太久沒有來
一個月沒來
很久不來
你這樣不行
你這樣比人家每個月都來的差很多
沒關係 我們之後每個禮拜都有來
好 每個禮拜都有來是不是
好 那我最喜歡的旋鼓
你最喜歡的旋鼓
最喜歡的是上上下下啊
上上下下最舒服
我本來是知道你進進出出啦
現在你又上上下下 又要進進出出
上上下下
因為有些東西要往上
有些要往下
誰往上誰往下
你要節奏感要用好
用不好會骨折的
看一下
誰要往上
通常我要做多的話
我會希望大戶
他跟我站同一邊
大戶持股要往上
大的要往上
好 第二個
我會希望主力
要跟我一起買
有力氣的要往上
有力氣跟我一起往上走
然後呢 這個我希望散戶啊
人多的地方不要去嘛
我希望散戶呢 是離開這一檔的
比較菜的 比較弱的要往下
對 我們要專業一點
這個太多人的就不要去
另外呢 這個假如散戶是用融資的話
融資不一定是散戶或主力
那假如散戶的融資的話
我也希望呢 它是退潮的
那這種股票呢 會比較好一點
如果它跟散户持股一起下降
就比較能猜到應該就是散户的融資
對 你就用這個猜就可以了
這好很聰明 你只要看到
散户往下 融資往上
那個就是主力的融資
所以很好分辨
所以兩個上 兩個下
先確定找到這個圖
對 沒錯
所以我們觀察的重點
來看第一個就是主力的買賣槽
你第一個是先看主力
雖然剛剛最上面一排是大戶
可是你是先看主力
先看主力
因為大戶它是每個禮拜公布一次
主力是每天公布
每天都有
大戶我們大概只能等一個禮拜
週末的時候看一下
有哪些最近是主力大戶大增的
或賞戶大增的
那一個禮拜才能更新一次
主力買一超每天都可以看
我問一下
像大戶我們都說持股400張以上
持股1000張以上
主力是持股多少以上呢
主力呢我们是全台湾
这个前15大
买卖的前15大分点
PK
就是买超的前15大分点买了几张
卖超的前15大分点买了几张
两个去PK
得出来的数字
好
所以他每天下午4点多
大概就会公布
好就是看坏的15大分点
看好15大分点
加在一起
如果是买超
那就是做多的厉害了
做都比較厲害
那你再去看一下
這個阻力是波段的
還是一夜勤的
是
那我們還蠻喜歡他一夜勤的
對
他假設一個晚上
今天大買他明天就要大賣的
是
這種阻力呢
你就跟著他做當中
也很好玩
就跟你說你喜歡進進出出啊
可是有些人就喜歡弄場一點的
躺著不動的
對啊
躺著不動蠻無聊的
聽說躺著不動
那個還會稍微變遠一點是嗎
你說骨魚嗎
他說他就是喜歡躺著什麼都不要做
你看看
躺著就能賺錢
好
那第二個呢
這個大戶持股呢
大戶持股呢
這個目前市面上
你可以去掉這種400張600張800張1000張
那通常我覺得啊
其實買到400張
我很少看到散戶在買400張的
對啦
很少
所以通常我覺得只要400張以上
他都大戶了
能買到400張的散戶也是大戶啊
對也是大戶啦
所以400张大户
那产物持股呢
这个大部分都是看100张
所以你就可以用这两个集序来看
那第四呢
我们再来看融资
融资呢
我们就看它到底是主力融资还是产物融资
好 刚刚有讲
如果说大户在增加
融资也在增加
应该就是主力融资
好 那种区间呢
我们设定看半年到一年
蛮长的耶
对对对
因为你这样子看呢
这个你大概知道主力的动向
因為通常做一檔股票不會一下就做完
好
接下來我們就看最近最標的一檔股票
車用電子 以利電
2497以利電
我們看一下
以利電這一段蠻厲害的
它在這邊是在做盤整
哇 這個一般人抱不住
好 那盤整的時候
其實它的主力有稍微慢慢增加
其實是有偷偷增加
然後到這裡
這邊就是我們看一下
這邊是主力買 上軌翹趙還記得吧 我們的第一季主力買上轨翹老婆開心老公也開心
翹了大家都開心
好 那這個翹的過程中
這個主力是每天在看
他主力只買
然後等到一個禮拜後你再去看
哇 大戶是增加的
對 而且是明顯的增加
閃戶是下降的
閃戶可能覺得
這段橫盤我已經受夠了
一涨我就賣
對啊 一翹就趕快賣
賣了之後呢
你看後面的漲幅呢
他都沒有跟到
那這個主力呢到底是
這個用不用融資呢
我們就看融資這個點
你就看融資跟主力有沒有同向
那你看融資假如跟主力同向呢
他就主力用融資
我們看這邊呢
這邊是這個有點同向的味道
所以主力用融資
所以這張股票呢
他最近看起來就蠻強的
不過到這個位置
我們看大戶持不比率在上個禮拜
突然驟降
對 上個禮拜
就再升起來
對 他之前驟降因為在高檔
高檔主力就出掉一些
想不到在上一週
突然
也就是在上個週末
我一看數據
怎麼一粒電大戶400張以上
大升了3%多
這真的好驚人
你看這一針
我們是以3%為界
這一針大概快到5%
然後散戶大幅的下降
也就是說這一根
阻力又進來
那我們就來看一下下個禮拜
這個大戶有沒有持續性的增加
有持續性的增加的話
這邊可能就不是高點
因為它前波在這裡有個高點
結果它創了新高
創的新高
那最近呢
這兩天因為處置的關係
有稍微休息一下
那等到這種
假如這個處置一段時間之後
它要出關
它可能又會有行情
好 這真的很巧
奇怪 主力一增加
會不會散戶買買
買成變大戶
應該不會
本來100張以下
一直買 變成400張了
那他們家就很有錢
是不是
可以在100張買到400張
那也不是普通人
那個也要4千萬
是
好
那第二個呢
也是最近很厲害的
很厲害的一檔股票
就是創委
高速傳輸的創委
創委
創委我們看一下
大戶持股比率呢
也是慢慢的增加
不過他這中間可能會有投信會不會
對有有有
這個也有算進去
因為這種大戶散戶呢
他們都是看這個ID的
看ID的
那這個可能有算進去
那我們看
散戶持股比率呢
他在這邊是在下降
那主力呢 最近
像最近他也呈現買超
可是他是一買一賣
這種一買一賣我們還蠻喜歡的
隔日沖的感覺
那這種一買一賣的
你要上車的節奏就很清楚
你要上車你就等這個賣超的時候上車
你賣超呢
黑K
黑K你就尾盤上車
隔天又變大紅K
所以這種
這種上軌翹的你不要去空它
那你反而可以找機會上車
那最近呢
主力在買我們看到
主力用融資買
是很看好的意思嗎
對很看好
開槓桿了
對而且講究效率的
講究效率
短期要把錢賺到
對因為一般融資的利率呢
到達6%
對
所以你從來沒有聽過人家用融資在存股
是的
融資不能存
因為殖利率5%
你拿6%來存
很奇怪
所以融資講的就是效率
最近主力又進來買 又是融資買
所以這檔各位你可以觀察一下
不過短線它真的漲蠻多了
短線上我們來看
從去年的60元之前還更低
去年的快到60元到現在已經漲了4倍多了
不曉得小哥還記不記得
670元的時候你說台東人有在買
你還記得 我記得啊
國差台東
對啊 因為像我這種人就只能65到70元
那時候就說他買很多
對 想不到現在已經270了
相關人現在還在東森裡面
開一個節目
真的喔 對
哇塞 最近新聞也很多啊
這股票就好了 開什麼節目
這股票都賺翻了
好 這創委
好 那創委呢 漲得有點多啦
所以這個你要買你要很小心
我們來看一個負面案例
這個張獻集團超喜歡這檔名
還是要強調這不是東森電視
詹命其妒人最近都在嗆我
嗆你啊
他說小哥你這個股評人士
股評
對 台灣人哪有人在講股評
股評是中國那邊才在講股評
股票評論人士
聽起來有點還不錯啊
股評人士
我們台灣都講財經專家
籌碼專家
我們台灣比較不好 名嘴
我用名嘴
對啊 上次這個因為詐騙集團
他們在喊東森
那我們就講解東森的籌碼
可能擋到他們財路了
後面他還做一個小哥跟詐騙集團的
偽裝對話你知道嗎
偽裝對話很多人一看
小哥又不是這個頭像
很多有我賴的人都知道
我頭像又不是我
是我小孩子小朋友的時候
所以這個你看
詐騙很猖獗
但這個詐騙就好笑了
台股沒開盤他也叫你下單
對 就被揭穿
他們最近都叫你去開一個很奇怪的戶頭也不是付委託因為你現在去開付委託你的銀員會擋你你是不是被騙了就跟銀行說怎麼突然來匯錢給美國軍官一樣
對
美國軍人那一種
最近要開付委託還不好開
所以他們現在用了另外一個套路
不是開付委託
開他們自己的APP
你知道嗎
你看有些人很笨
人家叫你下載APP
這樣把你的身份證 電話號碼
什麼都輸入
那你不就被那個詐騙機場痛窄了嗎
因為你的個子都被人家知道了
然後這個APP你還要入金
哇 你入得了金
你大概出不了金了
對 真的要提醒大家
詐騙現在手法越來越進步了
真的要注意
而且自己學起來真的比較快
對 我跟你講
你進去有兩種情形
以你賺錢 賺錢你是不是想出金
出金還可能跟你講說
哇這出金呢
你可能還要再揮一筆保證金才能再出
哇這是詐騙的連環套路
這很恐怖 很可惡的
因為這一檔是詐騙集團前一陣子非常愛用的
在喊的股票通聲
那通聲我們看一下
在高檔73塊的時候
那這個是還原
這是最高檔其實更高
大戶持股比率就在下降了
散戶就在上升
主力就在賣
這邊很清楚喔 有沒有看到
這裡主力賣的時候
這融資出現的大增喔
這融資是在高檔出現的
它漲那一波是為了航運喔
然後後來又在講他們有直銷
所以還是要強調跟東森電視真的沒有關係
它漲那一波的時候
假航運真直銷
對 假航運真直銷
可是我們看到籌碼 籌碼爛的要死
然後有個分點
在永差开户的一个分点
狂卖 卖几万张
我们看到他卖几万张的
那最近你看永差分点赚翻了
因为他卖在这个四五六七
四十几五十几六几七几
最近股价剩下三十几
还减资过
那筹码就是烂
那这种筹码烂的任何反弹
有没有看到
这边都有稍微的反弹
反弹都是逃命的
那就有詐騙集團說
東森這個反彈跟前波的走勢很接近
就會再創一波
整個笑欸 那我可能再創一波
因為這個上面套牢了一缸子的散戶
套了一缸子散戶
他要再拉一波讓你解套
不可能啦
所以你研究籌碼趨吉避凶
你都不研究
你都不看我們理財答案秀
對 你看這個大戶比例是極降
光這樣子就要有警惕了
對啊 這個我們都教你看籌碼
你不好的研究
你相信社群裡面隨便的人跟你講
那這種被騙也是這個
好啦 我覺得不管怎麼樣
不要把白花花的錢交給人家
人家如果抱你名牌
買了賠錢停損出場就算了
把錢給別人是最糟糕了
他們現在太狠了
好 我們冒著生命危險
我們還是要講
各位不要被騙了
歌有愁必報是最正直的節目啦
好 那接下來呢
我們剛剛講的是那個
假航運真直銷
接下來是假航運真百貨
百貨公司義航
這個呢 前波
各位在去年6月的時候
也是一樣
不知道趙華還記不記得
董事長
對 我跟你講 董事長嘛
把股票
董事長賣到57張
賣到一個極限
57張啊
我都想这个买58张跟他拼了
我也要跟你拼董事长
结果他在什么时候卖股票
这边有四个点
这四个点就是申报转让的点
所以你看董事长卖股票
我们那时候说
董事长卖那么多
你不要去追啊
我们苦口婆心
我们后来还有被观众骂
观众来来来
你现在看你骂我
我在23、24块跟你讲
你要小心
你还骂我说
你怎么可以唱衰他
結果現在剩多少 剩11塊
這邊真的要跟觀眾朋友說
不過我相信喜歡我們的觀眾朋友都知道
有時候我們講一檔股票的籌碼已經變不好
就事實來說提醒風險
不是我們在看壞它或唱衰它
或它人很好 籌碼很棒
硬要說它不好
不要都提醒風險了
然後還在怪我們
我們講這個都拿圖給你看
這種圖都是證交所公佈的圖
而且我們也沒有批過
申報轉讓那時候我們特別強調
不見得股價就一定馬上高點
可是一定有問題
一定有問題
你看真的
現在跌下來我跟你講
董事長又可以再買回來了
你現在就沒辦法選董事長了
那時候不趕快買
因為董事長現在可以慢慢吃貨了
那我們看在高檔的時候
這400張持股比例其實就在下降了
你看這蠻明顯的
那散物你看
散物原本40%
後面已經快到70%了
你知道嗎
哇 这次党股票现在都散户持有了
等到呢 他有一个大利空
哇 你想看到一个大利空
散户开始呢 狂丢股票的时候
这时候董事长就可以再买回来了
好 那我们看到在高档谁买的呢
融资
这种融资呢 就是比较散户的融资
所以我们讲
高档你看到散户大买 融资大增了 完蛋
再搭配申報轉讓 文字耶
後面就真的跌下來了
好 大家正要留意
因為有時候大家看到
想說後面還有在漲啊 你們在亂講其實都是一個短期的現象長期來看就是幾乎不變的定律都一樣啦一些壞消息都集合在一起對啊 我們都提早講在前面了
因為籌碼走在股價前面
來 接下來呢
剛剛講完那個義行
義行是去年夏天的名牌貨
是
現在已經這個今年的春天了
已經過了三季了
沒錯
接下來講一個去年冬天的名牌貨
冬天漲了很多化學化工
去年冬天的時候化工股漲很多
中華化
標股
你看當時的籌碼主力
這有到快到70%
可是它的主力為什麼剛好在相對高點
突然來個
我跟你講
出貨嗎
這我知道
這不是出貨
不是啊
這剛好有個隔日蔥
隔日蔥在漲停的時候買太多
買太多
買太多立馬變成400張大戶
但是呢
通常我們都講400張大戶
你應該是很真心的嘛
對啊
結果那個隔衝沒有
我不是真心的
我只是想買它
不小心啊
隔天我就要拉高出貨了
結果沒有
隔天立馬跌回來
所以後面之後慢慢砍下來
所以有時候會突然出現這種拉一波的
你要看是不是隔衝造成的
那我們從長線來看還是往下
對
那散戶持股比例也是一如的往上
那主力也是一路的賣超
只要有一個大買的
隔天都大賣
那這種你就知道
它就是隔日沖
那隔日沖
那漸漸的主力賣超這條線
是越來越下面
也就代表是怎麼樣
這個主力都一直在出貨
那融資大買一天之後也在賣出
那這種也是短線的融資
不是波段融資
那這種股票呢
你也是要小心一點
最近的股價反彈到月線
又要準備往下
但散戶又在持續增加
看起來有點嚇人
中股票有反彈都是拉逃命波的
因為很多散戶會覺得之前飆過了
現在是不是要再做一次
所以帳篇集團用這一套來講的時候
真的很多人會相信
真的
他們都會這樣想
他買股票
他們都跟百貨公司的
買特價品的觀念一樣
看到打8折就想買
看到7折更想買5折all in
就看他打2折
好
那另外一檔呢
也是標股
17開頭的
那這些呢
都是去年冬天的名牌貨
那冬天我們來看
去年冬天
去年冬天11 12月
這個1721三晃
最高點33.45
然後我們來看
這個在股價創高的時候
其實大股已經在跑了
大概從這個6 70%
已經降到剩四幾%
那閃戶呢
我們看閃戶從二十幾%拉到了50%
非常勇敢
哇 這檔股票一堆閃戶進去
那這麼多閃戶進去
各位記得最近他會拉一個逃命
還是會拉一個逃命
就是這個空頭就是這樣子
就跌下來跌到下通道就
這個反彈到月線
那反彈到月線呢
就是要跟你講
這個少輸為隱
所以反彈到月線
你還是要找機會出掉
那他的這個融資
我們看融資也是在高檔進來
那最近看融資也還沒退
所以這融資看起來也有點危險
好 不過這個三黃跟剛剛的中華化
都有一個現象 小哥
就是大戶走得比較快
其實股價還在往上走
然後大戶就減了很多
這樣子會讓人家覺得說
好像散戶這段比較厲害
散戶有賺到錢
那我們都說這種你要看誰笑到最後
誰笑到最後是不是
像東森一樣啊
東森那個大戶他40幾塊開始賣
好 不是東森電視的東森
對 2614的東森
40幾塊開始賣 賣到70幾塊
那時候很多人笑他
罵他 到我
沿路賣的意思 賣那麼多
那我記得我在籌碼Key我就發個文章
我說這大戶是比誰笑到最後
不是比現在誰笑得最大聲
你現在你可以笑得很開心
像之前美德1到6 70塊
散路多開心啊
但誰笑到最後呢
就是在六七十塊把股票賣掉的人
你看美德一下剩十幾塊
而且可能沿路賣
均價也不見得賣得很差
對 這個回過頭來看
你等到今年的冬天
你回過頭來看
你會覺得哇賽
他賣得還真的很漂亮
是
好 所以大家有些錢
剛剛小哥講得好清楚
有些錢其實你有時候手腳要快
因為你可能會笑不到最後
尤其是你看到大貨在賣耶
怎麼股價在往上走
其實你警覺心要起來喔
而不是說亂講
大戶雖然賣股價還是一直漲
到最後可能就會受到重傷啦
那當然本集呢
是講小哥的操作心法
大家一定很好奇囉
那現在小哥用他的這套邏輯
有沒有在觀察哪些股票呢
好小哥最近在關心的標的
有多喔
也有比較不好的喔
會在我們的榮耀班
來告訴大家
來跟大家做一個好好的分析
好今天小哥大放送
把他自己平常選鼓的邏輯
告訴了大家
你說難嗎
其實沒有很難
就叫做什麼
上上下下
有兩個東西要上
有兩個東西要下
其實我相信學起來並不難
當然籌碼的部分
因為要經過統計
有時候會運用到一些
軟體的統計工具
這個是不免俗的一定要的
所以希望大家
能夠把這個工具學起來
把方法學起來
希望大家都變成
第二個有沒有
全正小哥
那今天的歌有成必報就到這邊了
我們下次再見 拜拜
拜拜